>> Tucker: IN RECENT YEARS,
THE LEFT'S MORAL VOICES, THAT
WOULD BE MADONNA, JENNIFER
LOPEZ, LEONARDO DiCAPRIO,
PEOPLE WHO COULDN'T FIND THEIR
WAY UNAIDED TO EL SEGUNDO HAVE
DISCOVERED THE AMAZON RAIN
FOREST WHERE TERM IS OUT BUYERS
SOMETIMES BREAK OUT.
THEY SAY THE AMAZON RAIN FOREST
BEING DESTROYED, CRITICIZING
CHINA IS RACIST BUT BECAUSE OF
BOLSONARO OR SOMETHING?
THE EARTH IS IN THE BALANCE.
WE ASKED HIM ABOUT THAT.
IS THE AMAZON BEING DESTROYED AT
THE RATE THAT WE READ THAT IT
IS?
>> NO, THAT IS NOT TRUE.
TWO-THIRDS OF THE BRAZILIAN
TERRITORY ARE CURRENTLY
PRESERVED AND REMAIN PRISTINE
AND JUST AS THEY WERE BACK IN
THE 1500s WHEN THIS COUNTRY
WAS DISCOVERED BY THE
PORTUGUESE.
THE CRIMINAL ACTS THAT DO
HAPPEN, WE WILL NOT DENY THAT.
THERE IS A HUGE INTEREST IN
MAKING OUR SOVEREIGNTY OVER THE
AMAZONIAN REGION A RELATIVE FACT
OR PERCEIVED IN A RELATIVE
LIGHT.
I MET WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN AND
THANKED HIM BECAUSE ON TWO
OCCASIONS WHEN THIS ISSUE WAS
DISCUSSED WITH OTHER COUNTRIES,
HE STATED THE AMAZON REGION
BELONGS TO THE BRAZILIAN PEOPLE,
NOT TO ANYONE ELSE.
THE AMAZON REGION IS AS FAST AS
EASTERN EUROPE, IT'S HUGE.
IT'S WONDERFUL.
IT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE TO TAKE
CARE OF EVERY SQUARE METER AND
THE AMAZON REGION.
THERE IS ILLEGAL DEFORESTATION,
THERE ARE FIRE OUTBREAKS BUT NOT
AT THE RATE THAT IS ANNOUNCED
OUT OF THERE.
CALIFORNIA ITSELF ALWAYS CATCHES
FIRE AND IT'S NOT A GIVEN THAT
MUCH VISIBILITY.
FRENCH GUIANA LIKEWISE, YOU
CAN'T POSSIBLY SET A RAIN FOREST
OF FIRE BUT THERE IS ILLEGAL
DEFORESTATION, WE ARE WORKING TO
TACKLE THAT AND HOW CAN WE SOLVE
THE ISSUE?
IT DEPENDS ON THE BRAZILIAN
PARLIAMENT.
IT DEPENDS ON LAND
REGULARIZATION.
WE NEED LEGISLATION TO BE PASSED
TO THAT EFFECT.
IN THE FUTURE, AND HEAT FOCUS
DIRECTED BY A SATELLITE WILL BE
POINTED TO THE ULTIMATE OWNER
WHERE YOU SEEM TO HAVE A FOCUS
OF FIRE OR FIRE OUTBREAKS
BEGINNING, YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHETHER IT BELONGS TO THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION OR TO A
PRIVATE OWNER OR TO THE
RIVERSIDE PEOPLE.
SOMETIMES THE RIVERSIDE
POPULATION SETS FIELDS OF FIRE
FOR AGRICULTURAL PURPOSES AND
THAT TECHNOLOGY WILL CERTAINLY
HELP US PREVENT ANY KIND OF
DEFORESTATION.
THE AMAZON REGION IS AS FAST AS
EASTERN EUROPE, IT IS NOT EASY
TO TAKE CARE OF.
THE INDIGENOUS RESERVE ITSELF AS
BIG AS TWICE THE TERRITORY OF
THE STATE OF RIO DE JANEIRO
WHICH IS A BIG STATE.
WITH TECHNOLOGY, WE WILL
CERTAINLY BE ABLE TO PRESERVE
THE AMAZONIAN REGION.
WE DID NOT DEPEND ON
INTERNATIONAL INTEREST TO
PRESERVE THE AMAZONIAN REGION,
IT IS OUR OWN INTERESTS AND WE
OF COURSE WANT THESE
PRESERVATION EFFORTS TO BE
SOMEHOW RECIPROCATED BY MEANS OF
CARBON CREDITS.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE OPPOSED BY
MOST ACTORS IN BRAZIL AND
CELEBRITIES, MODELS, TV
PRESENTERS.
WE LEARNED RECENTLY THAT MARK
RUFFALO ALSO DOESN'T LIKE YOU.
YOU DON'T SEEM TO BOTHER HIM AT
ALL BY THIS.
Y?
>> IF I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT ALL
THE CRITICISM I GET I WAS NOT
ABLE TO WORK.
NO ONE LIKES TO BE CRITICIZED
BUT THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO DID NOT
UNDERSTAND ANYTHING ABOUT
BRAZIL?
I THINK THESE PEOPLE HAVE NEVER
BEEN TO THE AMAZON REGION I
WOULD ACTUALLY INVITE THEM TO
COME TO THE AMAZON REGION AND
ABLE SEE AN OUTSTANDING REGION,
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO OVERFLY IT,
YOU WILL SEE NO FIRE OUTBREAKS,
YOU WILL NOT SEE THE DEVASTATED
AREAS.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE AMAZON
REGION BECAUSE IT'S TRENDY, IT'S
A FAD TO.
IN EUROPE IF SOMEONE SAYS THE
AMAZON REGION IS NOT BEING
DEVASTATED, THEY ARE POLITICALLY
DOOMED TO FIASCO.
IT'S POLITICALLY GOOD FOR THEM.
CRITICISM YIELDS POWER, IT
YIELDS MEDIA VISIBILITY, YIELDS
VOTES AND THAT IS WHAT
CELEBRITIES FEED ON.
THEY ARE NOT AT ALL FAMILIAR
WITH THE AMAZON REGION, THEY ARE
NOT AT ALL KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
THE REGION AND THE DIFFICULTY OF
INVESTING IN IT.
THEY JUST CRITICIZE IT BECAUSE
IT'S A FAD.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T SEEM THAT
BOTHERED.
HAVE YOU ENJOYED BEING PRESIDENT
OF BRAZIL?
>> I MUST ADMIT I FIRST LAUNCHED
MYSELF AS A CANDIDATE, OF COURSE
I INTENDED TO BECOME THE
PRESIDENT BUT I WAS ALL TOO
AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES AND THE
DIFFICULTIES AND THE EXPERIENCES
WE HAVE UNDERGONE OR I HAVE
UNDERGONE, I COULD'VE NEVER
IMAGINED IMAGINED WHAT IT WOULD
LOOK LIKE.
I AM COMFORTED BY THE FACT THAT
THE OTHER CANDIDATES, THE
WORKERS PARTY CANDIDATE, IF HE
HAD WON, BRAZIL WOULD CERTAINLY
BE WHAT VENEZUELA IS TODAY.
THAT IS A SOURCE OF COMFORT TO
ME.
THAT ENCOURAGES ME TO THE STATE
OF THE POPULATION, GOD IS THE
ONE WHO WAS PLACED ME WHERE I AM
TODAY.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
A MESSAGE THE AMERICANS, GOD,
THE HOMELAND, FAMILY AND
FREEDOM, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Tucker: THE MAIN REASON WE
CAME TO BRAZIL WAS TO REPORT ON
WHAT CHINA IS DOING, SO THAT'S
BEING IGNORED ON PURPOSE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
CHINA IS WORKING HARD TO TURN
THE DEVELOPING WORLD INTO A NEW
COLONY, A COLONY OF CHINA AND
THAT'S PARTICULARLY TRUE IN
BRAZIL, A COUNTRY WITH THE
RICHEST NATURAL RESOURCES IN THE
REGION.
BRAZIL, A MILITARY BEACHHEAD FOR
CHIN